[Música]
hoy en el debate hablaremos de medio
ambiente debido al inicio de la Cumbre
climática de la ONU que tiene lugar en
el prestigioso Resort de charmel Shake
en Egipto el evento tiene lugar en un
momento muy complejo para la humanidad
la guerra en Ucrania los estragos de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 que siguen afectando
fuertemente a las economías de los
países un año en donde hay crisis
energética y también ha habido múltiples
desastres naturales que han resultado
devastadores la Cumbre concentrará sus
debates en el compromiso de los países
industrializados para abordar el
calentamiento global y también para
pedirle a los países más desarrollados
que cumplan con los compromisos sobre
todo que ayuden a los países que
resultan más afectados por el cambio
climático son cerca de 200 países o
Estados los que están invitados a este
evento que comenzó con una alerta por
parte de Antonio Gutiérrez el secretario
general de la Organización de las
Naciones Unidas escuchemos
en solo días la población mundial
cruzará un nuevo umbral el miembro
número 8.000 millones de la familia
humana nacerá este hito pone en
perspectivas de lo que se trata esta
Cumbre climática Cómo responderemos
cuando ese bebé número 8.000 millones
tenga edad suficiente para preguntar qué
hicieron ustedes por nuestro mundo y por
nuestro planeta cuando tuvieron la
oportunidad
excelencia esta conferencia de la ONU es
un recordatorio de que la respuesta está
en nuestras manos y el reloj Sigue
avanzando estamos en la lucha por
nuestras vidas y Estamos perdiendo las
emisiones de gas de efecto invernadero
siguen creciendo la temperatura global
sigue aumentando y nuestro planeta se
está acercando a un punto de inflexión
que hará que el caos climáticos sea y
reversible
cuáles son los llamados Yo lamento
decirlo pero son los mismos que hemos
estado oyendo desde hace muchos años en
este tipo de eventos que la humanidad
está en un momento decisivo que es el
momento que es ahora que puede ser ya
demasiado tarde pero por ejemplo los
líderes de Rusia de China de India y de
Estados Unidos que son algunos de los
países que más contaminan en el planeta
no están el luden esta cita o lo harán
dentro de algunos días Esta es una cita
que tiene como lema para este año Juntos
por la implementación pero se podrá
implementar todos los pactos acordados
hay poco interés por parte de las
grandes economías a la hora de tomar
medidas contundentes para qué sirve este
tipo de eventos entonces en donde hay
una
expectativa y poco impacto porque en la
práctica son pocas las cosas que se
llevan a la realidad al campo a la hora
de realizar las acciones por qué no hay
mayor presión sobre esos países más
avanzados que son los que más contaminan
el planeta qué mecanismos pueden crearse
para garantizar que haya verdaderos
avances en cuanto a los compromisos que
ya llevan durante muchos años los países
adoptando a través de acuerdos a través
de este tipo de conferencias la copa 27
cumplirá su cometido pues es alguna de
las preguntas que vamos a analizar en
este programa para conversar sobre este
tema hemos invitado a Isabel Aguilera
analista medioambiental ella también es
experta en temas relacionados con el
cambio climático y gestión energética
ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
Santiago en chile y
en Egipto se encuentra Leonardo lacerda
Él es director global de clima en
generator conservan Sí ustedes nuestros
televidentes también les recuerdo que
pueden ser parte de este debate pueden
dejar los comentarios preguntas que
tengan Yo sé que este tema
medioambiental les interesa a ustedes lo
pueden hacer A través de las redes
sociales a través de Twitter Facebook e
Instagram déjenos saber sus opiniones y
sus comentarios no se encuentran como
arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta se la recuerdo para
que dejen los comentarios numeral el
debate f24 todo Unido todo pegado no
olviden también que todos los contenidos
de nuestro programa están también
disponibles en podcast nos encuentran en
Apple podcast en Spotify en deezer y en
TuneIn
entonces la palabra a Isabel en la
ciudad de Santiago Isabel Bienvenida al
programa Gracias por acompañarnos mucha
expectativa en torno a este inicio de la
Cumbre de la Copa 27 y comienzo tomando
las palabras de El lema de la Cumbre
para este año Juntos por la
implementación hay unidad para esta
implementación Cuál es su opinión
Muy buenas tardes
la verdad es que son tiempos difíciles
venimos saliendo de una pandemia o
seguimos viviendo una pandemia y hay un
contexto de crisis internacional
vinculado con la guerra Australia
no son los mejores momentos para
plantear grandes avances o grandes
anhelos en torno al tema de cambio
climático pero el compromiso o de
implementar
acciones que ocurren una mejor inmediata
en mi entorno
puede ser algo que cada uno de nosotros
puede hacer
ahora la bienvenida a Leonardo que él se
encuentra justamente allí en
charmershake en las costas del mar Rojo
Leonardo bienvenido Gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa su opinión
hay unidad para poder lograr esta
implementación Isabel habla de la
coyuntura internacional que resulta muy
adversa para los países y para los
compromisos pero por lo menos esta
Cumbre podrá pasar de las buenas
intenciones a las acciones
Pues es lo que esperamos creo que hay
una acupuntura que no es demasiado
favorable Pero
hay cambios que son importantes por
ejemplo los Estados Unidos han acabado
de pasar legislación al nivel general
que a 14 años esperábamos que pasaran
entonces habrá recursos en Estados
Unidos para hacer algo desde su parte
los cambios en Brasil políticos también
son muy importantes y creo que
podríamos ver progresos ahora hay unidad
no sé si estaría tan de acuerdo con lo
que has dicho que
se está siempre hablando y no se hace
poco Es verdad que hay que hacerlo mucho
más pero
hace 20 años más o menos los las
perspectivas eran de llegar al final del
siglo Entre cuatro y cinco grados más
[Música]
bajos bajo sí
solo pero ahora la perspectiva es más o
menos entre dos punto seis hasta tres
entonces hay hay progreso Pero lo que
hay que hacer ahora es la implementación
por ejemplo los precios
de los renovables de la energía
renovable se cayó muchísimo entonces
podemos acceder este proceso hay algunas
oportunidades muy interesantes por
ejemplo Indo ha bajado el 90%, su
deforestación esperemos que Brasil ahora
pueda hacer lo mismo sí pero así que
estoy un poco más optimista de lo que se
puede hacer hay mucho optimismo siempre
se llena de optimismo a raíz de esta
Cumbre Leonardo Isabel pero por ejemplo
la parte superior citó algunos medios
que han traído esta información a la
comunidad internacional y es que dentro
de esa lista de temas para abordar en la
cop 27 estaban esos 100 mil millones de
dólares al año que los países en
desarrollo prometieron en el año 2009
entregarle a los países que están en
vías de desarrollo para poder reducir
las emisiones y poder adaptarse al
cambio climático
según el reporte este dinero debía haber
sido entregado en el 2020 estamos en el
2022 Qué pasó
exacto
no han cumplido
los últimos números para el
2020 eran solamente
80 mil millones pero
mi organización trabaja mucho con
[Música]
si trabaja mucho con este tema de
financiación nuestra propuesta es que
los 58 países más pobres de la tierra
los que sienten más los efectos del
clima
tienen una deuda con los países más
ricos y con China de más o menos 500 mil
millones de dólares pudiéramos estar
haciendo cambios de deuda
reestructuraciones de deudas para el
planeta es decir hacer fiestas deuda
pueda estar pagada con por recursos que
vayan hacia los desarrollo de renovables
para la adaptación de los países y la
conservación de la biodiversidad que son
crisis comunes crisis comunes esta
primera parte del debate la voy a hacer
críticas a diferentes puntos luego vamos
a analizar lo que hay en las agendas de
los países no nos vamos a quedar en lo
negativo de una vez se los digo vamos a
ver también El lado positivo de las
cosas para hacer balance en la
información Pero sigo también citando
otras personas que están allí en la en
la Cup Isabel por ejemplo ligado que es
el director general del departamento de
cambio climático del Ministerio de
Ecología y de medio ambiente de China
que es justamente uno de los países más
señalados a nivel internacional por
contaminar
él dice que esta Cumbre no carece de
metas que las metas ya están que se
están es acumulando las metas y faltan
las acciones pero china es uno de los
países que menos avances da o por lo
menos no se le da a conocer a la
comunidad internacional hay Avance
significativos en China explícanos hay
como Cómo entendemos esto porque lo que
vemos es que se acumulan las metas y los
intentos pero las acciones son pocas
quisiera rescatar de que existe hoy en
día una conciencia mucho más fuerte
respecto
de el compromiso climático el compromiso
en la exigencia ciudadana porque las
cosas ocurren mejor yo eso ocurre en
Chile me imagino que ocurre en otros
países del mundo y en chino también debe
estar ocurriendo el movimiento ciudadano
está
presionando para que lo soluciones
ocurran quizás no es inmediato el el
resultado pero yo siento que la
organización de la sociedad civil está
haciendo un rol fuerte por generar una
adaptación a esta nueva forma de vivir
con el cambio climático
Y es de la misma manera como ahora
exigiendo en esta Cumbre que se compensa
a aquellos países que tienen mayores
vulnerabilidad entonces siento que bien
los países grandes que están están
evadiendo concretamente sus compromiso
de alguna manera eso tiene que ocurrir
en algunos minutos porque la demanda
social lo va a intencionar así Isabel
otra pregunta que queda sobre la mesa es
la articulación entre los países más
desarrollados y los menos desarrollados
y los países que ya están siendo
víctimas contundentes del cambio
climático eso eso Esas naciones estados
insulares por ejemplo en Oceanía en el
Índico o los países que tienen grandes
ciudades en las costas que también se
ven afectados por diferentes eventos
naturales qué tanto se están articulando
los países esa articulación se hace a
través de gobierno a gobierno millones
de organismos internacionales como se
está mejorando esa colaboración
lo que yo entiendo es que hay distintas
maneras de abordar en la zona
centroamericana existe una
vulnerabilidad es común que hacen que
los países tengan una negociación hacia
algunos fotos climáticos en específico y
otros países como chile que tienen otro
tipo de vulnerabilidades tiene un
espacio digamos de negociación hacia
otro tipo de financiamiento climático
hay negociaciones por supuesto en bloque
en grupo que son mucho más beneficios y
eficiente pero también hay cosas
puntuales que tienen principalmente con
el tema energético que permite
incorporar tecnologías de países
desarrollados en
tanto para poder
incorporarlo dentro de su nueva matriz
energética y generar soluciones
iniciales Leonardo su opinión sobre esta
articulación entre países ha avanzado ha
mejorado ahí hay buenas hay ejemplos de
buenas prácticas entre esta articulación
de países
ahí estoy de acuerdo que falta mucho
en la última conferencia de las partes
se dijo que se iba a duplicar los fondos
para la adaptación es decir llegar por
lo menos a 40 mil millones de dólares
eso no se ha hecho y en esta conferencia
de las partes ahora se va a discutir
si se debe crear un mecanismo para lo
que se llama las pérdidas y danos es
decir las los efectos que son
irreparables es decir que por ejemplo
cuando se pierde una isla porque el
nivel del mar se ha aumentado pues quién
lo paga que Para dónde va la gente en
esto en las negociaciones No todavía no
no llegaron a un punto de consenso
entonces va a ser un tema bastante
discutido es donde esperamos tener mucha
discusión en esta
hay pláticas mejores etcétera es
esfuerzos grandes sobre todo en los
países que son Islas por ejemplo de
entender cómo adaptarse como criar más
fuerte resiliencia a los problemas
de adaptación al clima por ejemplo en
los países costeros sabemos que Los
corrales y también los los manglares
reducen mucho el impacto de Los
Huracanes etcétera entonces la
naturaleza ella misma puede ayudar si es
el caso que después de un huracán se
pueda restaurar estos hábitats pero así
que hay buenas prácticas etcétera Pero
el consenso global sobre este tema tiene
que ser todavía
Leonardo Qué países hay a nivel
internacional que estén liderando este
tipo de lucha que estén dando resultados
contundentes que sean países abanderados
de la lucha contra el cambio climático
pero que evidencian de verdad un cambio
significativo veíamos por ejemplo la
Unión Europea muy abanderada algunos
países por ejemplo Dinamarca el interior
de la de la Unión Europea muy
abanderados con el tema medioambiental
pero ahora la coyuntura económica les ha
obligado a dar pasos hacia atrás en
muchas de las políticas adoptadas uno de
los países que puede ejemplificar esto
es Alemania que ha tenido que volver
casi que al carbón para poder mantener
su su nivel energético debido a la
crisis con Ucrania Pero qué países hay
que lideren que sean ejemplo que se
puedan dar a conocer y tomar como
evidencia de buenas prácticas
bueno con la guerra en Ucrania
los países europeos están haciendo un
esfuerzo gigantesco un esfuerzo de
guerra para hacer la transición
energética más rápida no Entonces se
comprometieron a llegar al 45% de los
las energías renovables hasta el final
del 2030 es y es una oportunidad muy
grande ahora hay mucha oposición por
ejemplo las ongs que no quieren que esto
los renovables sean establecidos en
áreas protegidas o cerca de de ciudades
que son patrimonio histórico de la
humanidad etcétera entonces
lo que estamos trabajando mucho en la TV
es para identificar las áreas que son
adaptables y las mejores áreas donde la
energía pueda ser
implementada entonces aquí estamos
hablando mucho de implementación Cómo
mover como acelerar esos procesos
Entonces no estás discutiendo donde no
hacerlo pero donde sí hacer la
implementación de las energías
renovables y Europa es un excelente
ejemplo de esto
creo que es en Estados Unidos ahora que
habrá dinero de del programa Federal que
se creó y otros países como India ahora
te digo algo quién está pagando por la
adaptación son los propios países pobres
cuando ves la cantidad de dinero que se
paga para la adaptación no es muy poco
está Viene de los países más ricos y eso
hay que cambiar sabes que el 50%
de los países desde los más pobres en el
mundo su responsable solamente por 16%
de todos los gases estufas que los gases
que se han puesto en atmósfera entonces
hay un problema de equidad Hay un
problema de equidad y de responsabilidad
y esa es la responsabilidad la vemos
Como algunos de los países que
contaminan más la atmósfera Como por
ejemplo Estados Unidos y China hay
expectativa porque tal vez estos dos
países puedan volver a conversar sobre
temas climáticos sobre cómo los dos
pueden adoptar procesos para poder
empezar a reducir sus emisiones pero
pero hayan listas que dicen que tal vez
Washington y China no estén interesados
en conversar por lo menos en el marco de
esta competencia que tanto mal le hace
esto a la a la realidad climática
mundial Isabel que Estados Unidos y
Washington no quieran Estados Unidos y
China no quieran asumir
responsabilidades
yo creo que
yo creo que hay hay voluntad de poder
generar soluciones en un gran porcentaje
de los habitantes de ambos países hay
que intentar no
caricaturizar pero finalmente
hay negociaciones que deben hacer y yo
creo que la buena buen criterio y la
buena voluntad debe estimar
esperemos que sea así y esperemos que
así como los impactos son tan fuertes y
se demoran tan poco tiempo en impactar a
la población y a los territorios
se logre concretar soluciones en el
corto plazo soluciones basadas en la
naturaleza
en términos de regeneración u otros son
posibles pero demoran en estar
disponibles y Leonardo su opinión sobre
esta falta de conversación entre
Washington y Beijing
yo creo que los países en desarrollo
tienen que hacer más porque no no no van
a poder más contar con
una
asociación más fuerte entre los Estados
Unidos y China por cuenta de los
problemas geopolíticos que tienen ahora
entonces hay que hacer un esfuerzo en el
pasado del grupo del eje 77 por ejemplo
ha hecho mucho para danzar las cosas del
temas para el desarrollo no en el pasado
más de 100 teníamos los bricks los
bricks no que hicieron también bastante
avances entonces quizás ahora con
Ya hay que pensar otros otros tipos de
mecanismos de negociaciones
internacionales en que hagamos hagamos
de tal manera que China y Estados Unidos
estén influenciados por otros también y
ahí hay este increíble hay países
pequeños que tienen bastante influencia
Y estoy pensando por ejemplo en Costa
Rica que da excelentes ejemplos de cómo
de cómo un país pequeño relativamente
pobre puede hacer mucho por el clima no
entonces basado en buenos ejemplos claro
Isabel justamente que Leonardo menciona
a Costa Rica como un país destacado en
la región hablemos de América Latina la
agenda que hay en América Latina países
con iniciativas destacadas políticas que
puedan llegar allí a la con 27 que sean
destacadas o que sean líderes en la
región aquí hay un punto importante y es
que América Latina solamente contamina
el 10% en bloque Pero además no negocian
bloques cada país va con su agenda y eso
también dificulta un poco tener una Un
fin común entre todos los países
es cierto es una desventaja en cada país
negocia por sí solo ahora para temas
para temas comunes existen negociaciones
desde hace mucho tiempo y se va
trabajando en el desarrollo de buenas
soluciones en cada uno de los temas no
desconozcamos que existe este
relacionamiento entre los socialistas
que están generando una solución para
que luego se produzcan las definiciones
finales en América Latina hay grandes
esfuerzos porque somos una región
resiliente somos una región recipiente
porque tenemos eventos en todo sentido
que nos
acercado a los nuestra estrella ya los
conflictos desde siempre nosotros
tenemos muchos terremotos tenemos mucho
inundaciones
por nuestra configuración geográfica
tenemos costas con
océanos un complejo entonces finalmente
hemos tenido que adoptar y adaptarnos
desde siempre a generar soluciones
basadas en la naturaleza que nos
permitan aminorar los impactos Ahora
yo diría que hay significativamente la
incorporación de energía renovables
convencionales en la materia energética
chilena por ejemplo es un ejemplo
estamos con un porcentaje altísimo de
energías renovables no convencionales
nuestra matriz que nos permite
digamos
contar con plantas con parques eólicos y
otro tipo de
infraestructura energética alternativa
de muy buena calidad
y estamos también trabajando en digamos
todo
como la protección de nuestra área
vulnerable en los bordes costeros hay
trabajos significativos de recuperación
de
recuperación de
áreas en marinas
destacadas por sus características
particulares de
biodiversidad
hay muchas iniciativas Leonardo pero esa
unidad podría ser un paso importante
para la región es decir
podrían los los gobiernos actuales
proponer una unidad en bloque de América
Latina para para poder tener iniciativas
medioambientales comunes así como lo
hace por ejemplo África que sus 54
países negocian en bloque América Latina
podría seguir ese ejemplo
es seguro lo que yo diría es que es
imposible de quedarnos
entre 1.5 grados o dos grados al máximo
hasta el final del siglo sin un papel
muy activo de latinoamérica en las
soluciones
basadas en la naturaleza
aquí hay quizás nuestra más grande
contribución sería en la reducción del
de la desforestamiento
y ahí hay dos temas principales son la
soya y el ganado
y creo que verdad que hay que tener más
políticas públicas para bajar esto por
ejemplo Brasil ya había bajado por el
80% en el pasado las deforestación
y perdimos todo esto ahora
este último gobierno el el aumenta el
70% la deforestación entonces quizás
ahora con el nuevo gobierno podamos
volver a que la situación en el pasado y
lo que creo que es además de los estados
no nuestras compañías
deben hacer también su parte no por
ejemplo tenemos a
jds que es una de las más grandes
exportadores de carne en el mundo que
tiene sus responsabilidades y varias
otras organizaciones
de las cuales tenemos orgullo porque son
organizaciones
compañías latinoamericanas que han
conquistado el mundo pero bueno tienen
que demostrar su responsabilidad global
responsabilidad global y también B1
algunas alianzas interesantes hay
algunas iniciativas entre Brasil la
República democrática del Congo e
Indonesia que usted ya lo mencionaba
Leonardo en su intento por disminuir la
deforestación que están preocupados por
la deforestación de sus selvas
tropicales y están buscando hacer
sinergias entre los tres países hay más
iniciativas similares de otras partes
del mundo de otros países de América
Latina que se puedan citar que se puedan
destacar en el marco de la cop 27
hay iniciativas Pero quizás este sea la
más interesante bueno eso que se anunció
como quizás hacer una opec de las de las
de los países de bosques
quizás hace una oportunidad de traer a
esos países Juntos por ejemplo yo estaba
hoy con la delegación de de Indonesia
ahí hay ejemplos increíbles de Cómo
bajar en los 90% como he dicho la
deforestación en siete años cuando hay
voluntad política se hacen las cosas
ahora lo que se está discutiendo aquí es
la creación de un mercado de carbono no
uno de los temas muy importantes de esta
discusión es el artículo el artículo 6
de la convención uno de los últimos que
hay que terminar de país entonces ahí
pensar mecanismos buenos de mercados de
carbono global que sean también no sólo
mercados voluntarios pero también
mercados
al nivel jurisdiccional en cada uno de
los países hay ejemplos excelentes de
reducción de
deforestación bajo esos sistemas
jurisdiccionales como ya Bueno me queda
ya pocos minutos para finalizar el
programa las conclusiones quiero que las
enrotemos justamente en la
implementación Isabel por dónde comenzar
las implementaciones en nuestros países
es necesario que el primer paso sea no
sé por dar una idea implementación de
leyes a nivel político o empezar por
reforzar una educación en los jóvenes
mucho más conscientes del medio ambiente
o la creación de fondos o por dónde cree
usted que puede darse esa implementación
por lo menos en nuestra región
entendiendo las dificultades que tenemos
es multidimensional sin duda que la
mayor
variable en juego tiene que ver con el
financiamiento climático para poder
Acceder al financiamiento climático hay
que estar sumamente bien calificado para
poder entender la forma y el mecanismo
de acceder esta financiamiento se
requiere un capital humano altamente
calificado para poder acceder a ellos
luego una educación ambiental permanente
multinivel y incorpore la buena práctica
ambiental como un desdén como un como
una condición básica en nuestras buenas
comportamientos habituales en cada una
de nuestra vida
luego necesitamos tener compromisos
políticos que se
concreten a través de la gobernanza
instituciones adecuadas
legislaciones adecuadas pertinentes a
cada territorio y que
sean fáciles de aplicar fáciles de
fiscalizar y que ya hagan sentido a la
gente como una buena nueva conducta que
adoptar Sí y Leonardo Cuál es su
conclusión como implementar estas Cómo
llevar esto a la práctica Isabel habla
de un punto importante que sea
multidimensional será tal vez la la el
resumen de su de su conclusión Cuál es
la suya Leonardo ayen charmershake es
muy muy parecida
la naturaleza puede darnos el 30%
del esfuerzo que es necesario de
mitigación Hasta el 2030 Entonces yo veo
esta conferencia aquí en San Merced como
si fuera una fuente para la próxima
reunión de la convención de la
biodiversidad la convención de la
diversidad biológica que habrá lugar en
Canadá
Entonces mi esperanza es que ese tema de
[Música]
soluciones basadas en la naturaleza se
vaya
arraigar tener sus raíces y y llevar
también a una mejor a un mejor resultado
de las próximas negociaciones en
Montreal para la diversidad biológica
pues Isabel Leonardo les agradezco mucho
por haber llevado este análisis esta
explicación de lo que sucede en esta cop
27 la Cumbre apenas está comenzando ya
veremos Cuáles son las conclusiones que
arroja este encuentro y lo que deja
estas dos semanas de encuentro de
diferentes líderes de los países
alrededor del mundo muchos temas sobre
la mesa para debatir y sobre todo mucha
ansiedad por parte de la comunidad
internacional de poner en práctica y de
llevar ya esto a conclusiones verdaderas
y resultados visibles les agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros a
ustedes Muchas gracias por la sintonía
la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de nuestro compañero Giovanni y la
producción de invitados estuvo a cargo
de Tania Herrera muchas gracias a
ustedes pueden seguir dejando los
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales
[Música]